الاشتباكات في الايام الماضيه فقط انحسرت
في دارفور مدينه
وهي اشتباكات بين الدعم السريع والجيش في
البدايه ولكن بعد ذلك تحولت الى اشتباكات
بين السكان في ولايه غربي دارفور مدينه
كما يعني تابعتم هذه الاشتباكات خلفت
العديد من القتلى والجرحى وحتى الان لا
توجد احصائيه دقيقه لعدد القتله ولا توجد
الاحصائيه
عدد الجرح في ولايه
الجديده
لكن دعني الان انقلك الى صوره اخرى انا
هنا في الميناء البري لمدينه الضعين عاصمه
ولايه شرب دارفور يمكن ان نرى صوره بهذه
الزاويه اليوم وجدنا في الميناء البري عن
الكبير من الذين سروا من القتال في
الخرطوم جاءوا الى مدينه على ظهر
العربيات الكبيره والصغيره مما يحدث في
الخرطوم يعني ما يغير الثلاثه الف مواطن
حضروا الى هذا المكان وما زالت الاعداد
متواليه قادمه من ولايه الخرطوم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات